okay so I've seen a lot of news articles
and internet posts recently about how
Tony Stark is dead due to the fact that
he is not anywhere in the spider-man far
from home trailer even just googling is
Tony Stark dead brings up millions of
results the main evidence for this comes
from the fact that Pepper Potts signs
the donation check in the trailer happy
says you are all along and Peter looks
at his costume with sadness personally I
think a lot of these are a bit of a
reach and when you watch the trailer you
don't really get the feeling for that
obviously we know that Pepper Potts is
now the sole CEO of Stark Industries so
this checks signing doesn't seem out of
place here looking at his costume with
sadness it could be because he has a lot
of memories attached to it and sort of
wants to leave the responsibility of it
behind happy saying you are all alone to
me means that the Avengers will not be
with him and that he is going out on
this trip without any real reach to the
rest of the team rather than Tony being
dead
recently I was sent a tweet by Katie Lee
who has contributed to my fan theories
before and what she says makes a lot of
sense in the tweet Katie states hey hope
you're good just noticed a few things in
the spider-man trailer the film is set
moments after end game when the smirky
dude says he respects spider-man etc he
mentions Thor and Iron Man and Pierre
isn't moved like Stark is gone far from
it
also when happy gives the check I'll
expect tears upon seeing each other got
me thinking though like what if the
biggest lie the Russo's have created
it's Captain America and Iron Man dying
or leaving the MCU in other ways and
actually put money on at least one of
them signing on for a few more films
personally this seems like the most
likely theory I mean happy hogan doesn't
exactly see my kiss changing his name to
sad hogan and I feel like the universe
would have a lot less of a positive
outlook if one of its biggest parts no
longer existed there are of course other
theories that state that far from home
actually ends before Infinity Ward
starts with Peters bus journey in that
film at being when they return from the
trip of course we won't know what's true
and what isn't until endgame is released
in April but until then it's fun to
speculate obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts and if you enjoyed this
video please like it and let me
your theories in the comments below make
sure you check out my fan theory on how
the elementals in the far from home
trailer may be illusions which is linked
after this video I've also included
Katie's Twitter in the description so
make sure you follow her from what ban
theories like this this is a channel for
people who are mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition that you've been
the best I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]
Oh